from cnr.com Dave Chappelle Compares Jim
Cary role to trans people this is taking
the Internet by storm Dave Chappelle's
new comedy special the dreamer is out
and the first joke he makes in his
special it's a master class in comedy I
think how long is it like s minutes long
it's a good it's a good build up he
tells this long story it's it's an
emotional roller coaster my dad died and
I'm I'm he says I'm I'm distress nor
McDonald and Andy Kaufman are in it nor
McDonald calls him on the phone and says
would you like to meet Jim Carrey and
Dave says he's my I'm I'm such a big fan
he then goes on to praise Jim Carrey as
like a natural talent that you just
can't learn he gives this really long
story about how he finally met Jim
Carrey Jim Carrey is is is method acting
as Andy Kaufman so when he shows up
they're like don't call him Jim call him
Andy and he's like what and he's like
this is so weird and he's like in
hindsight how amazing was it to get to
witness this artist in one of his most
powerful roles you know by the time I
got to admit I was disappointed and then
after this big long story and he's like
so there I am I know that's Jim Carrey
but they're making me say Andy and the
reason I tell you this story that's how
trans people make me feel like that
whole buildup was for that kind bang
like a shotgun blast now here's why this
is important Dave Chappelle immediately
then afterwards insults handicapped
people conservatives Madison cauthorne
specifically he makes specifically
specifically Madison korne he goes off
on Madison car it is brutal he make a
joke too while he's at it the
whole thing is mocking him for being
handicapped oh man he says he lost uh he
lost his re-election he lost his seat he
lost his seat as a handic he ran a bad
race ran a bad and the crowd is losing
it and then he goes on to claim that the
only reason anyone would invite Madison
coor to or and then he imitates a
paraplegic getting gangang I was
wondering if you're going to bring that
up but the reason I bring this up is
Dave Chappelle did not single out the
trans Community he literally made fun of
anybody he could and back to back
because he's not actually trying to
insult trans people he's making jokes he
then makes jokes about handicapped
people he makes jokes about Republicans
even he makes jokes about Asians and in
the same joke makes makes a joke about
black people he's just ribbing on
everybody and everyone's loving it
here's why I say all of it is important
Dave Chappelle is the goat okay they
call him the goat the greatest of all
time when he releases a Netflix comedy
special which is number one by the way
right now it's hilarious and he says
this is how I feel and I can joke about
these things he is telling regular
people it is now okay for you to joke as
well about conservatives about the
handicapped about Asians about black
people about trans people we just have
jokes yes he's basically setting that
Line in the Sand so now you know over
the past several years you've had people
who are scared to do comedy Jerry
Seinfeld talked about all those years
ago college campuses are insane all
these people getting canceled Dave
Chappelle comes out and says you can't
cancel me they tried they couldn't they
couldn't do it $20 million for a comedy
special and the first joke he does was
about trans people and he follows It Up
by saying I'm not going to if you if you
thought you were going to come to this
show and to hear me joke about these
people you thought wrong I'm not going
to joke about these people it was not
worth it maybe three or four times it
does an impression of a handicapp person
who came to a show to hear trans jokes
and then is disappointed that he's
hearing handicap jokes but then is then
later happy when he hears handicap or or
trans jokes again it's it's brilliant
and like I think his audience and a lot
of audiences comans it was DC and it's a
barometer of the culture right like
that's the the audience was just in love
right and there's that that feels really
good to see that when the whole crowd
erupts and cheats years when he finishes
the first joke about Andy Kaufman I was
like wow dude a DC liberal audience is
cheering and clapping for what he just
said about how he feels when he's told
he has to act like someone is someone
else and then when he mentions Madison
coor and someone goes oh in the audience
like clearly not a conservative not a
fan but there are a lot of people now
that saying Wess is dead it's been dying
out it was never popular to begin with
people were just too afraid of canc
culture when someone like Dave Chappelle
stands up and says dude I don't care I'm
telling I'm telling a joke and you can't
do anything about it he basically plants
a flag and now regular people can stop
being scared and call out the crackpots
that they don't like that's part of the
reason why 20124 is going to be kind of
or one of the many factors that is going
to make 2024 kind of crazy the people
that are interested in social justice as
leg as
legislation they are going to be holding
on to power they're going to be doing
whatever they can to pass
legislation that that benefits their
ideology and it's the same thing as like
when when the Allies were going towards
uh towards Germany they just ramped up
the killing the Jews because there it's
an ideology they like part of their
ideology was kill the Jews part of the
ideology of the left right now is to
implement social justice stuff into law
so they're going to be doing all they
can to to Ram laws that are as permanent
as possible through before the the
election in order to to you know hope
with in their opinion
hopefully push this as far as they can
because they I it's it's likely they see
that there's going to be a a a swing
back of the pendulum I think I'm glad
that they've overreached and they've
gone so far it's like Jujitsu you're we
can use their own momentum against them
because they've gone so far people don't
agree with it that Dave Chappelle making
what seems to be an inoffensive joke to
anybody in the world is completely
offensive to these people to the point
where they want to kill him and Sh shout
out to Dave Chappelle by the way the
only person to make a funny joke about
me that I enjoyed from the D me bro
thing like 15 years ago the only one
that made a joke I enjoy so sh shout out
to Dave Chappelle and uh I'm glad he's
doing his own material and not just uh
copying Owen Benjamin anymore just just
kidding just
Kidd you you got you got made fun of by
Dave Chappelle and that's when I when I
we watching it and he he second joke in
the ACT is M mocking Madison cauthorne I
was like man how lucky is Madison
cauthorne yeah he was a member of
Congress I mean not like not like uh uh
you know he probably would have been
happier if he didn't get primaried but
for Dave Chappelle to do a comedy
special making fun of you as a member of
Congress you you are you are Immortal
the joke he makes about you in that
moment and uh he says he saw him and he
yelled hey congressman and he looks over
him and he's mad and he's like and then
I and then I and and then then I walked
away I wanted to see him do some I
wanted to see I wanted him to see me do
something he couldn't do that's what he
says I'm like yo if that were me I was
getting made fun of by Dave Chappelle
I'd be like man honor honor it's a total
honor it's like why I love shows like
kill Tony too like Tony henchcliffe like
just roasting people that that to me is
the way my that's my favorite type of
Comedy not just the surreal stuff which
I also like but people just ragging on
you it feel it's that's catharsis and
that's why a lot of like when I saw
Louie get like quote unquote canceled
all those years ago I was like that was
the beginning of me really understanding
like they're going to take out artists
and comedy first cuz those are the
people who subvert the whole power
structure right and then Louie handled
it I thought very poorly with the
apology and stuff but and Chappelle did
the opposite thing he just doubled down
which I I appreciate that you know to me
no I just say to me it's like that's
that's more punk rock what Chappelle
does is punk rock you know Lou didn't
when when I got uh one of the times when
people were like giving me crap and in
response I wrote a song called Never
sorry that's how you do it yeah it is
that's exactly how you do it right like
you were saying earlier like you only
let yourself be canceled right they
can't do it to of course you can lose
your jobs and stuff and like they've got
normal people in the world who lose
their jobs but uh once you apologize
that gives them all the power over you
you're admitting you're admitting guilt
unless you did something wrong you feel
bad for it like go ahead and apologize
but like that's so rare but the thing is
when you are going to apologize you have
to apologize to a person that possesses
the ability to forgive you when you
apologize to a community no one has the
power to forgive you and they're going
to use it against you in the future
because you've admitted to it and then 5
years 2 years whatever down the road
when you pop up in someone's you know
sights again and they're like oh I
remember that guy he did this terrible
thing that we can crap on him again so
all I'm going to do is bring this up and
we can totally disregard what he says
don't give them the power don't say I'm
sorry because then you're telling them I
consent to your authority over me your
demand in an apology so I will allow you
to have that power over me get effed you
have no power don't be afraid to be
called anything any bad words Elon
buying Twitter was massive absolutely I
was here a just about a year ago and I
was banned from Twitter not allowed uh I
I shouted out a bunch of people Patriot
J old Rose Swig all banned and today
they're all back Alex Jones is back
Patriot J is great shout out Patriot J
yeah crazy it's a different world with
Alex Jones back on Twitter and with Elon
letting him grow and grow and grow so
2024 it's it's the best of times it's
the worst of times you know hundreds of
thousands coming through the southern
border but at the same time Alex Jones
being popular and mainstream on Twitter
very very different year we're going to
have it feels like meme magic is here in
full effect that that is one thing I'm
afraid of though because the
counterculture is going to swing so hard
back and now with people like Alex back
um but I feel like they're going to find
a way to subvert our subversion you know
like they're going to find a way to just
turn off the power you know the thing is
that bothers me when you're when you're
subversive or when you're when you're
dealing with people like you know in in
the world that we deal in where outside
of the mainstream narrative like just
because you hear a story that's outside
of the mainstream narrative doesn't mean
it's true or it's right and that's one
of the things that that the people that
are outside of the mainstream need to be
focused on right now just because
someone that is ex that is looked at as
outside of the the acceptable
conversation says something doesn't mean
they're correct in fact you have to be
more careful now we've had that fire
drill once before the qinon thing
everybody saw kon's not real I think
people are a little wiser than they were
last go around that people are being
able to spot whatever they try to throw
at us I think there is a decent
probability of some kind of cyber 911
people call it and that something cuz I
think it was like was it Bill Gates who
was talking about this the risk of our
digital infrastructure and and cyber
attacks imagine this scenario
uh first let me just say I don't know
the probability but I think there is a
possibility considering the stakes of
2024 the internet has gone down before
there have been cyber attacks over the
past several years we not them and then
uh there was one where Google actually
went down and all of a sudden nobody
could get to their websites because
people don't actually type in the
websites they type in the word press
enter and it pulls up Google which they
then click the thing what I'm searching
for things on Twitter I don't search
Twitter I search Google I'll type in
like Phil leonti communist meme X and
then it'll pop up with like his latest
post and I'll click that's how I find it
so when Google went down I forgot
exactly what happened all of a sudden
internet traffic dropped dramatically
imagine a scenario where for some reason
the Internet is just down just in in
general and the only information com out
is through terrestrial television CNN
Fox News
MSNBC imagine during the election we get
some kind of attack and that's what
happens imagine if just before the
election something like that happens
they can then say whatever they want
without being fact checked by anybody
else and no one can discount them there
may be a scenario like that I don't know
um it could be like oh no we get
attacked and the infrastructure goes
down and oh we better fix it we don't
know what's going on and it's an act of
War which we then use to justify some
kind of escalation somewhere else but
then also allows them to basically say
to a show like ours if you want to stay
on the air it's going to cost you like
what what do they charge a th000 bucks
an hour or something for for dedicated
satellite and uh what youall need to
understand about the way YouTube works
this is only possible this show is only
possible because YouTube pays for the
streaming costs what people need to
understand is when we we are streaming
right now at about uh 6,000 kilobits per
second that means for the 45,000 people
watching it receiving between 2,000 and
6,000 multiply that multiply that 6,000
by 45,000 and you'll get the actual data
transfer there's no possible way we
could afford that it's only possible
because of these website subsidies so
when you see like Rumble they're
spending a pretty penny to get those
shows out because they want to make that
work so shout out to rumble YouTube of
course is subsidized by by Google it's
not it's not that extreme we may
actually be able to uh uh like what we
what we would just do is it's 10 bucks a
month to subscribe to the show and then
we could use that money to pay for the
for the stream and all that stuff but it
just basically it would make it make it
so that literally anybody who wants to
watch has to pay
they're they're I I believe that's their
best attack Vector for shutting down the
kind of things I agree I mean there's
been so many reports about the internet
apocalypse and they're worried about
solar flares but from what I'm hearing
solar flares won't wouldn't probably
affect it I think what they would do is
blame it on a solar flare and then just
shut it off you know on their own and
then prevent us from uh subverting the
narrative like a lot of us were doing
during lockdowns or you know talking
about election stuff uh that's going to
be tough that's why I've been I've been
very open in my community about how I
feel about everything you know I'm
building a people in my immediate
Community who I know I can trust and
agree with you know maybe nothing will
happen but I don't want to be in in a
spot again where I'm surrounded by a
bunch of idiots like I was in New York
and and not handle like the society just
being ripped to shreds I think even the
speculation of us talking about this it
puts a it puts a a wrench in their plans
because if everybody is thinking ahead
of time oh these people want to do
something evil to stop us if something
like this were to go down every one
knows where to point the finger thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net